[Music]
matt is with us in albany new york hey
matt how are you
i'm good thank you thanks for having me
sure man what's up
so
i graduated from college one year ago
and uh hopefully i got a good job and
i'm about to pay off all my debt from it
uh but
uh as i pay off my debt i kind of feel
guilty about how much my parents
contributed to paying for my college and
i want to pay them back except i'm not
exactly sure
where it should kind of fit into my the
kind of baby steps and then the best way
to go about paying them both back is
that my parents are divorced and they uh
contributed different amounts so i don't
know if you guys help me out with that
is there an expectation for you to pay
them back like is it something where
they expect it or is it something you
just want to do out of generosity
uh
no they don't expect it there's never an
agreement i just i feel
i feel like i want to do it and i have
two younger siblings going about to go
into college and i can tell they're
really stressed about it and i feel like
uh i i feel kind of bad for uh i feel
like i feel like they paid all the money
a lot of the money that they had saved
up for me and i want to help my siblings
out too i guess
that's very kind of you what other debt
you had you said you're about to pay off
the rest of your debt
uh it's all just federal loans um
in a matter like in a week or two i'll
have all the money to pay that off
completely so it's basically uh
basically a baby step two
how much money are we talking about with
your mom and dad
uh so my mom paid in about 50 and my dad
paid in about 15 okay and you make what
now
uh 75
okay
all right
well there's nothing morally wrong with
what you're doing there's no moral
uh or legal obligation for what you're
talking about doing you understand that
right right okay and so
as long you know that does make it what
christina said that it makes it an act
of generosity on your part
um
i don't like that you use the word
guilty
because you're not guilty
i'm a dad who paid for my kids college
and i'm not i have no desire for them to
feel guilty about that
it's something i did as a parent i was
able to do it i did it it's done
your your little brothers and sisters
your siblings uh that are going to
school have they got the money to send
them
uh
i
they um i i guess that's the other part
i don't i don't know like the exact
numbers of all their financial
the whole financial situation but i know
like there's a lot of stress there's a
lot of discussion about it and
so they had a college fund for you or
they are they cash flowed you
uh like basically cash flowing me i
guess okay and now they're they're
struggling with i think there's a little
so why are they struggling with cash
flowing the next one
uh i i mean
i guess it kind of comes down i don't
know the exact
situation yeah i don't know that all the
numbers i feel like a little awkward
like asking for my parents like
financial
information but
okay yeah
um
now this
you're doing this blind okay and blind's
not good
um you have a sense
in the air that they're stress and that
may they may not have enough money but
you don't really have that information
and that added with your gratitude for
them taking care of you and the
awkward weirdness of them doing it
through a divorced process
that that also is in the air and that's
screwy right and awkward
um and so you've got all this stuff
going on you got this whole this this
whole gumbo this whole soup here that
you're stirring up but we don't even
know what the ingredients are so if you
want to be generous you need to be
generous with knowledge
and so i would sit down with your mom
have a cup of coffee and go this is what
i'm feeling
now tell me where you are with your
finances
because i i'm kind of thinking i may
need to help you out so that you can
help the siblings out
tell me what's going
on and and if she says look i told you i
was paying for college i'm in good shape
shut up
then shut up and move on if she says
yeah i'm freaking out i don't know what
i'm going to do then you may want to do
this generous move if you want to
okay and have the same conversation with
your dad but let's let's have uh
all the cards of the relationship and
the situation face up on the table so
that everybody them and you all know
what's going on here
and by the way tell your mom that you're
having the same conversation with your
dad and your dad you're having the same
conversation with your mom there's no
secrets here there's no hidden corners
there's no darkness that shadows that
things are hiding under it's all out in
the light
and then the answer will be very very
plain as to what you're supposed to do
if your suspicions are confirmed and you
want to go ahead and you do it all from
knowledge
i'm with you go do it i would not just
write checks into a blind crappy
situation and you don't know what's
going on
that makes sense
yeah and it's good for the relationship
too because you're manning up
you're looking at your mom and going hey
i'm like a grown man and stuff and i'm
making 75k
i can help in this situation she goes no
i got a million dollars over here i
never told you about
you know
but she just generally she just
generally is a person who worries or
frets you know i don't know
i don't know i don't know what you're
going to find out but at a minimum
you're going to find out more than you
know now
well the other way you can be generous
with knowledge is
you can also help your siblings like you
can help them
work through the logistics of going to
college so of course it's great if your
parents can cashflow college but the
kids can also work they can win
scholarships they can get tuition
assistance programs there's all sorts of
ways to graduate debt-free so if there
is an actual money issue and your
parents don't have the money to pay for
your siblings college perhaps then you
can step in as a mentor you sound like
you have an excellent head on your
shoulders you're doing well financially
you can step in and mentor your siblings
to figure out how to pay for college
themselves and also if you move on to
baby steps you know get your fully
funded emergency fund get into four
through six if you have some extra
perhaps you can help your siblings
financially but i think there's a lot of
ways to look at this yeah and it can be
both you can mentor them and write some
checks into mom and dad if you find all
this out so let but let's not just go i
kind of have this vague sense of guilt
like i got money and they're not and
they don't have it and the kids are gone
you know and then i'm just gonna start
writing no i don't write checks into
blind funds
albright checks into blind situations
and it's not it's it's it's a good
relationally cleaning thing to have this
conversation it's going to be it's going
to be beautiful
so and you're a good dude man that's a
great heart on your shoulder a great
heart a head on your shoulders as you
said heart and everything the whole
somebody who actually wants to do this
is that that's just cool yeah good on
you for getting ready to pay off the
rest of your student loans like that
sounds
amazing you said next week you're going
to be able to pay everything off so
we're really proud of you that's
incredible yeah making more money he's
ever made in his life got out of college
living the dream and we're going to take
a 65 000
pit stop here and take care of mom and
dad if we want to
um or not
depending on what you find out you might
find out some
wonderful things you may find out some
things that are not so wonderful but
you're going to find out more you know
now
and that's what you need to do